the next presentation is in the nimble
hands and nimbler feet of a football
hero who when his off seasons earned his
letters sa g4 Screen Actors Guild and
the Klansmen and then the towering
inferno the Buffalo Bills OJ Simpson to
help him to help him carry the ball an
actress you first saw in cabaret and
most recently with such style and
elegance in Barry Lyndon the second most
beautiful girl I've ever seen
Marisa Berenson
there are two categories for short
subjects the nominees for best
achievement and animated short films are
great Bob Godfrey producer kick me
Roberts would but he says mischief
achieve initial draft they're no longer
not energy producers Sisyphus Marcel
Yankovic producer great Bob Godfrey
did you see that TV program about the
British being finished well forget it
we're still in there
I would just like to thank the Academy
and my fellow technicians and a very big
thank you to all those people back in
London who work for so long for so hard
for so little to enable me to win this
the ottoman accolade thank you very much
and God bless
for best achievement in live-action
short films the nominees are angel and
Big Joe Bert Saltzman produces conquest
of life Lois
Marcus producing during flight Lawrence
and Landsberg and produces a day in the
life of Bonnie to solo very spinel Oh
double talk Alan Beatty producers a
constant feature and the winner is angel
and big Joburg salsa
boy am i I'm nervous
I want to thank the members of the
Academy and especially the members of
the short film committee and I also want
to thank a few people who work with me
on a number of my films and who really
gave their best
Linda Gottlieb learning Corporation of
America my cameraman Paul Glickman my
editor Armand Levitz I'm nervous
my music man all Innova
and last but not least a dear friend a
wonderful human being and a man who
helped me pull it all together
mr. l ron hubbard and also thank you
Frank Capra wherever you want